welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber we have a major update
on fraud perpetrated by the now Infamous
Alec Murdoch the disgraced South
Carolina attorney convicted of killing
his wife and son Murdoch confessed that
he lied about some of the details
related to the death of Gloria
Satterfield his family housekeeper and
Nanny at mozell now we remember that she
died in 2018 three years before Maggie
and Paul Murdoch were gunned down on
that same property Satterfield was found
at the bottom of the home's front step
she never regained Consciousness and
died a few weeks later Murdoch had
claimed that Satterfield tripped over
the family dogs and fell but he now says
he made that up Murdoch had suggested to
Gloria satterfield's sons that they file
a wrongful death lawsuit against him so
that they could get a huge insurance
payout in reality the four million
dollar settlement went into Murdoch's
pocket the convicted killer revealed
this new information in a court filing
as he responds to a lawsuit from
Nautilus insurance company Murdoch
admitted that he said the dogs were
involved because he wanted Diwali could
to ensure settlement happened but he now
says that the dog the dogs were not
involved in the fall and that Gloria did
not regain Consciousness Murdoch says
she was not at the home to work her real
reason for being there however was not
mentioned in the court filings attorneys
for Murdoch actually suggest that the
satterfields need to return any money
that they got from the settlement
because the wrongful death lawsuit was
filed under false pretenses now Tony
Satterfield one of Gloria's Sons
testified during Alec Murdoch's murder
trial prosecutors say Murdoch killed
Maggie and Paul because he wanted to
distract from all of his financial
crimes Tony said Murdoch hid all the
settlements from the Satterfield family
did he ever tell you about a 505
thousand dollar settlement that already
had occurred no
did the defendant ever tell you that he
also had a five million dollar umbrella
policy no
did he ever tell you that there had been
a recovery against that no
did he ever tell you that had been a
recovery for 3.8 million dollars against
that no
did he ever pay you one penny of 3.8
million dollars no
all right I'm joined right now by my
co-host defense attorney Brian buckmeyer
and we have special guests former
prosecutor Bernardo villalona is with us
great to have you both here Brian I'll
start with you why would lying about the
dogs increase his chances of a
settlement I mean how and also how does
this all affect the criminal case all
right so like many people who have dogs
in their home they know that there can't
be fully trained or fully controlled so
the idea of a dog bumping an elderly
woman and having that woman fall to be
injured into her death kind of makes
sense and it's an easy narrative to
control that my dog property as the law
sees it hurt this other person and it's
understandable within the realm of
negligence or recklessness and allows
him to control the sentiments for all
parties involved not when it comes to
criminal charges each and every lie
could add on to being a separate charge
not only run concurrently but could be
run consecutively Bernard I need you to
make sense of something from him because
he Murdoch was on the stand he pretty
much confessed to all the financial
crimes during his murder trial you think
this is actually going to go to trial or
he's going to take some sort of plea
well
Thor will be in the best entrance of
Alex Murdoch who actually plead guilty
on the financial crimes why because this
overwhelming evidence of his guilt and
financial crimes as we saw in the
homicide case so you notice that the
homicide case that Alice Murdock did
testify and he admitted to the financial
crimes however in South Carolina those
have missions in that criminal case
cannot be used against him in another
criminal case unless you're looking to
charge him with perjury so in terms of
the case in Chief the prosecution can't
use his admissions however if Alex
Murdoch were to testify and testify
conversely to what he testified at the
criminal trial having to deal with the
murder then they can cross-examine him
on that I'm so glad you mentioned that
that's a little tidbit of South Carolina
law that I always want us to mention
because you know it was a big topic
about whether or not he had just walked
himself to jail not so clearly
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody we have new information about
court documents filed in a lawsuit
between the parents of Gabby batido and
the parents of her fiance Brian laundry
the potato family is accusing the
laundries of negligence after Brian
killed Gabby during a road trip and left
her body in Wyoming as we know he then
returned to his home in Florida and then
took his own life leaving behind a note
admitting to the killing the potatoes
contend that his family knew he had
killed Gabby but did nothing and instead
offered up a statement hoping that she
would be found safe they say that that
caused a lot of emotional distress the
trial was supposed to start soon but was
pushed off to 2024. attorneys for
Stephen bertolino the former laundry
family lawyer have filed a list of
questions with the court that they want
the potatoes to answer bertolino was
added to the lawsuit in January Joseph
petito and Nicole Schmitz say he issued
a statement in 2021 hoping Gabby Patito
would be found alive when the plane of
selege he knew she was dead they say
that that made statement extremely cruel
the questions are seeking Clarity on
things like whether the petito family
has ever worked with Steven bertolino
before in his capacity as a lawyer and
what they authorized their own attorney
to talk about publicly when it came to
the statement about wanting Gabby to be
found safe in 2021 long crime spoke with
Stephen bertolino not long after Brian
laundry's skeletal remains were found in
Florida our Anjanette Levy asked why the
laundry family didn't contact the
potatoes here's what he told her back
then
backwards I can tell you at this moment
in time we have you know nothing to say
to the petito family uh right now
Christian uh Christian Roberto laundry
are just focusing on you know retrieving
Brian's remains from the medical
examiner's office uh grieving their sons
and dealing with that and in the future
you know we'll see what happens uh with
respect to you know not speaking uh to
the petito family in the beginning you
know that was on me that was something
that I told them they shouldn't be doing
and we're just going to leave it at that
did they want to speak to the Patito
family in the beginning
and Jeanette I can tell you it's not
about what they wanted it's about what I
told them they needed to do
Bernardo I get what the family is
looking for but wouldn't anything said
between bertolino and the laundries be
protected by attorney-climb privilege
so normally that is the presumption that
anything you say between your attorney
is protected by attorney-client
privilege however there are exceptions
to that so if the purpose of the
communication is the commit of fraud or
to commit another crime then you can
Pierce that attorney-client privilege so
the burden is going to have to be on the
party that's claiming the attorney crime
privilege to say that what was said or
the information that he possessed is
actually attorney-client privilege and
that there was no crime that was
committed Brian is it possible that
bertolino was aware that the laundry
parents knew where patito's body was and
if so what could be the repercussions
for him I mean Jesse in a world of
possibilities I guess anything is
possible but you're suggesting that an
attorney knew as Bernardo laid out there
that a crime was being perpetuated and
this Falls outside of the attorney
client privilege and that he's helping
them by evading prosecution and the law
enforcement by not saying where this
body is and that their son is on the run
there will be ethical ramifications he
could lose his license he could be
charged for aiding and abetting
tampering with Witnesses or or even just
obstruction of justice there are many
criminal and civil liabilities that this
attorney can face so I think that's why
a lot of people are scratching their
head and saying why would he go out on a
limb like this and say what he did with
so much on the line you think he would
know better which I think is why a lot
of people think this might not be what
the laundries are or the potatoes are
thinking it is well look as I said it's
been pushed over to 2024 we'll see what
happens between now and then and maybe
we'll get some more information about
what was happening behind the scenes
we're finishing Today's Show with
another big update in the case of Brian
Walsh Massachusetts Court's documents
show a ransom note was sent to a
detective after Anna Walsh was reported
missing it reads we have the so named
Anna Walsh with us here we had a deal
worth 127 thousand dollars she messed up
we have her here with us and if she
doesn't pay the money then she'll never
be back and we know that the police and
the FBI are involved good luck finding
us
let's go through the timeline for a
second so the ransom note was sent via
email at around five in the morning on
January 7th two days before on January
5th Cohasset police asked the public to
help find on a wall she was last seen in
the early hours of New Year's Day then
on January 8th Brian Walsh was arrested
for misleading the investigation after
officers searched the couple's home
finding spots of blood in the basement
and on a damaged knife between January
9th and January 10th investigators
continued their search at the Walsh
residence along with a trash facility an
hour from Cohasset items recovered from
the trash facility included blood a
hatchet a hacksaw a rug and used
cleaning supplies eight days later on
January 18th Brian would be formally
charged with murder he's currently being
held without bail after pleading not
guilty and since Brian's murder charges
several New pieces of evidence have been
released by prosecutors from the day
Anna went missing they include
screenshots of Brian at Lowe's and Home
Depot Purchasing things like tools and
cleaning supplies he's also seen
carrying a heavy garbage bag near a
liquor store dumpster Brian's next
pre-trial hearing is scheduled for
November so Bernarda could this Ransom
note point to another suspect or
suspects and maybe it's a good thing for
the defense
so usually notes like this are a good
thing for the defense if the prosecution
can't link you to actually writing the
note itself but either way it's
something that had to be turned over and
will be turned over to the defense
because it's considered Brady meaning
that it's it's exculpatory in terms of
how it will affect the case again the
prosecution is going to be able to prove
that same evidence that you mentioned
about the Home Depot videos as well as
the blood inside of the home all of that
to be able to contradict anything having
to do with that note and be able to
argue to the jury that this is just a
red herring indicate problem is there's
just so much evidence against him
including the searches and the
surveillance footage but Brian
127 thousand dollars that Ransom though
that's such a specific amount why do you
think that exact amount so Jesse I got
you on this one at first I thought 127
thousand dollars who's paying off their
student loans right but then I listen to
the note that you just read where is the
instructions as to when and how to pay
this Ransom it's not there it seems like
this Ransom note might be a red herring
because if someone really wanted this
very exact amount wouldn't that note
also include we want the money at this
time by this deadline no it sounds or
reads like someone is trying to throw
someone off their sense and when you
look at all of the other evidence
against Brian Walsh it does appear that
he might be the culprit and this might
not in fact the exculpatory evidence but
it might be in culpatory evidence that
proves that he is the murderer just
trying to throw off anyone and everyone
off his tracks I don't know just a
theory I'll take the tinfoil hat off it
could be something else but that's what
I read there's so many bizarre details
in this case I'm not surprised this came
out but we'll see which way It
ultimately goes and who It ultimately
benefits Bernardo thanks for coming on
Brian always good to see you I
appreciate you both and everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Law
and crime daily we will see you next
time as we discuss Justice
[Music]
thank you